foreign
with the majority opinion about
something I don't think of myself as a
contrarian contrary to what most people
say about me but on this I must dissent
a manager in Olive Garden in Kansas has
been fired after sending an angry email
to employees telling them that they may
not call out of work for any reason and
if they claim that their dog died as an
excuse for coming to work they have to
bring the dead dog in as proof now the
manager whose name has not been
published thankfully was fired and most
people have applauded the decision after
the email went viral but I'm on the
manager side of this and I'll explain
why but first here's the story from a
local CBS affiliate it says a Johnson
County restaurant manager sent a harsh
message to employees about taking time
off and was subsequently fired in Olive
Garden media relations representative
confirmed to KCTV5 a manager at the
restaurant on 95th Street sent the below
message to staffers and here is the
message in full this is what it says
quote our call-offs are occurring at a
staggering rate from now on if you call
off you might as well go out and look
for another job we are no longer
tolerating any excuse for calling off if
you're sick you need to come prove it to
us if your dog died you need to bring
him in and prove it to us if it's a
family emergency and you can't say too
bad go work somewhere else if you only
want morning shifts too bad go work at a
bank if anyone from here on out calls
out more than once in the next 30 days
you will not have a job
do you know in my 11 and a half years at
Darden how many times I called off zero
I came in sick I got in a wreck
literally on my way to work one time
airbags went off and my car was totaled
but you know what I made it there on
time there are no excuses us
collectively as a management team have
had enough if you don't want to work
here don't it's as simple as that if
you're here and want and want to work
then it'll work no more complaining
about not being cut or not being able to
leave early you're in the restaurant
business do you think I I want to be
here until midnight on Friday and
Saturday no I'd much rather be at home
with my husband and dog going to the
movies or seeing family but I don't I'm
dedicated to being here as should you no
more excuses or complaints I hope you
choose to continue to work here and I
think we the management make it as easy
as we can on y'all thank you for your
time and thank you yeah to those who
come and work every day to work every
day and work hard I wish there were more
like you okay
as a message Olive Garden announced that
it had parted ways with the manager
after uh this was released it was a
predictable decision but the wrong one
now
obviously there's some hyperbole there
you shouldn't actually bring a dead dog
into a restaurant this is Olive Garden
not Panda Express for God's sake and of
course it's conceivable that a person
could have a reason to call out more
than once in a 30-day period I rarely
call in sick to work but I I missed an
entire week a entire week a few months
ago after I lost my voice not a lot I
can do without a voice though even then
I still dragged myself to work and I
recorded a segment in subtitles that's
how committed I am to my job
or it's how committed I am to trolling
you decide perhaps there's not much
difference between the two
anyway the point is that there there is
reason to object to this manager's
message to employees if you insist on
taking it absolutely literally
but a more charitable interpretation is
that this person is trying to run a
restaurant and yet is sabotaged every
step of the way by spoiled entitled
brats who want a paycheck but don't want
to put the work in to earnings
and these are frustrations shared by a
great many managers in the restaurant
and retail space and other industry
Industries call outs and no shows are at
an all-time high
and it's not because everyone's dogs are
dying all of a sudden it's not because
there's a record number of family
emergencies
uh if it's a if it's a medical emergency
driving this problem the medical
emergency is a severe allergy to hard
work I think is the that's the real
epidemic happening here this is an
Affliction which has spread across an
entire generation and Beyond
and the people who are trying
desperately to keep our economy afloat
by keeping these businesses open
they're fed up and they're Furious
and they should be
if I was in charge of Olive Garden I
wouldn't fire that manager I'd give them
I I give him a raise and a promotion
because this is exactly the no-nonsense
get your crap together attitude that we
need
now of course there is another side to
the story I made a condensed version of
the point I just articulated on Twitter
over the weekend and Lauren Southern
responded disagreeing with me saying
quote people are fed up working jobs
with no upward Mobility no living wage
thanks to inflation and no real benefit
to their Community multinational
corporations workers don't care anymore
because a manager that asks you to bring
your dead dog in clearly doesn't care
about them either now Lauren and I went
back and forth several times and
although this breaks the rules of
arguments on the internet we still
respect it and appreciate each other by
the end of it
um I've been a fan of Lawrence for a
long time and still him and she raises
an important Point here which which I
don't fundamentally disagree with it's
true that many people are disillusioned
and demoralized and they have no hope
they're dropping out of a system that
they feel is rigged against them so
she's right about that and I made a
similar point or at least a related
point in one of my monologues last week
it's an important aspect of this problem
and and it's important that we talk
about it but there are other realities
which also must be acknowledged
because this is not a simple matter of
the working class rising up against
their wealthy oppressors
the people left holding the bag here
such as managers at Olive Garden they're
working class too
and it's worth sticking up for them
and and on that note a few points first
many of the workers who are giving up
and throwing in the towel
Are Young
okay like late teens early 20s
these are not people who've been
grinding it out for years and years and
have finally become exhausted by it
most of the shift workers at Olive
Garden they are they're not going to be
people in their 50s who've been slaving
away for decades only to have their
opportunities for greater success stolen
away by various misfortunes and
calamities out of their control there
may certainly be some people in that
category but a greater number are young
adults in college or just out of college
uh or who never went to college but are
around that same age and if you're in
this this demographic and you've already
stopped trying
that's a whole lot less understandable
because you never started trying you
can't be fed up with something you've
never even done
you're in your early 20s how do you
think life is supposed to go for you at
that age do you think you're supposed to
enter adulthood and immediately be
rewarded with the kind of wealth and
Fortune and job security that most
people work decades to attain
what what did you expect working at
Olive Garden sucks
of course it does
of course it does no one ever said it
doesn't there's no version of working in
Olive Garden that won't suck
but you got to start somewhere you got
to pay your dues you have to work your
way towards whatever it is you want it's
it's not going to be handed to a very
small fraction of human beings in the
history of the world have been born so
wealthy that they never have to work for
anything in their lives
but if you like me are not in that
category then there is no option but to
build for yourself whatever kind of life
you want
or rather there is no other respectable
honorable option
unfortunately our society does provide
the option of coasting by living off of
the very system you pretend to oppose
while profiting from the work done by
others and as I've often preached you
know life requires work life is work
I wish it wasn't that way
but it is
the only question is whether you will do
the work necessary to to sustain your
own existence
or if you'll find a way to force someone
else to do it for you
door number two was never available to
most humans who have lived on the planet
but it is available for us
okay because as it turns out the system
that really controls things this is what
they want
they want you to be a lazy good for
nothing just coasting through life with
no ambition no no real desires no plan
nothing
they want you to be satisfied with being
merely uh fed and distracted
that's what they want
so they've made this option available to
us
now you think you could protest that
system by doing exactly what they want
by becoming the sort of person they want
you to be which is like a non-person a
non-entity just a big nothing
who does nothing and and it contributes
nothing at all to the world
so if you walk through that door
you will be entering into a life of mere
existence mere satiation
you will not find success you will not
find dignity you will not find joy
and most of all if you take door number
two you cannot pretend that you're above
it all that you're fed up with the grind
that you found a more enlightened way to
live
that's not the case because you're still
very much dependent on those who are in
The Grind
those who are doing what you will not do
and are now forced to work even harder
just to subsidize you
you notice that there's employees at the
Olive Garden don't want to put the work
in
they still want the paycheck right
but
in order to have a paycheck this this
restaurant needs to stay open needs to
exist
and they don't want to contribute much
to making that happen
but they need someone to do it
right they need they need enough people
there at Olive Garden to keep that damn
place open so they can keep keep getting
the paycheck they want
so they are just they are just uh
handing off all of those
responsibilities to someone else having
someone else do it for him
someone else who is also working class
someone else who was also not wealthy
they're not passing it off to the CEO of
Olive Garden you're passing it off to
the other to just whoever there at Olive
Garden to whatever Patsy you can find to
do the work that you won't do
because in the end you must work you
don't have to like it
you don't have to think it's fair
but if you wish to keep your dignity
and the moral High ground or any moral
ground at all
there is no other option
some people understand this like the
Olive Garden manager and they live
accordingly
and so often the ones who do the work
only get insult to add to injury time
and time again
they become the bad guy they're doing
everything
they're the only reason that these good
for nothings have a freaking paycheck to
begin with and they end up the bad guys
no not in this segment anyway that's why
it is not the Olive Garden manager who
was canceled but the lazy employees with
their fake dead dogs and made up sick
family members they are the ones who are
today canceled
and I'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block
thanks for uh hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]